[Music]
one of the issues about how we
understand there's all this today I
think the first thing to say about
mental illness today is that there's a
limit of mental illness in the world
today partly because we are creating a
very unstable world a very unequal world
and this is not good for human states of
consciousness so that's one reason why
this issue is of enormous and pressing
concern to most of us many of us have
had these experiences ourselves or know
someone very near and dear to us who is
having them so that's a kind of
political kind of starting point in
thinking about mental illness today I'm
also very interested in the
philosophical aspects of the thing
interested for example in difficulties
to do with diagnosis and questions to do
with whether mental illness is the same
kind of thing as physical illness or not
one of the things which is an important
matter to me in this regard is that I
think that mental illness is quite
different from physical illness in that
mental illness is something that we have
in the final analysis more control over
ourselves so one of the things I've been
thinking about and talked about quite a
bit recently is the way in which it is
possible for example in relation to
depression and anxiety to fight those
conditions to some significant extent
using philosophy the philosophy of the
Stoics for example from ancient Rome the
philosophy of Buddhism these are tools
that can be used to achieve some kind of
security in some kind of power over
one's mental states this is an ancient
wisdom if you will which gives people a
set of tools to tackle mental illness
and if those tools become better known
if philosophy becomes more influential
in relation to thinking about psychology
I think that could be a powerful new
wave for the 21st century really
interesting so the more we can invest in
in the better chance we've got - that's
really interesting to make give people a
sense of empowerment that they can
tackle these mental illnesses yeah yeah
I believe that I believe that
philosophical thinking and philosophical
understanding and the kind of agency
that that can bring about can be an
important way in which quite a lot of
very distressing mental conditions can
become less distressing and one can come
to have a certain kind of power in
relation to them which one didn't have
before so can you some examples can you
yeah so one of the basic things I'm
arguing is that when we think of mental
illness we think of something that's
wrong with us
Livi's is causing us distress that is
causing us suffering and one of the
quite controversial claims that I'm
making is that in a certain sense that
is the the wrong move to make them to
think there's actually anything wrong
with this in other words I want to say
that the part a key part of the way out
of of anxiety and depression provided it
doesn't get too extreme is to understand
that in a certain sense there really
isn't anything wrong with you and that
the kinds of distressing thoughts and
feelings that you're having are maybe
perfectly natural and that provided you
don't believe in them and get swept away
by them then actually there needn't be
any way in which this harm this
suffering that you've been subject to
continues so to make that even a bit
more concrete if you are faced with a
distressing repetitive thought one thing
you can do with that is to not believe
in the thought and to face the
distressing feeling or sensation that
goes with it to give that your your full
attention to meditate on it if you
and then what you will what you may well
find is that the the sensation or the
thought diminishes gradually kind of
goes away you can return to simply being
present in the present and that's partly
coming from the kinds of agency in power
that stoicism or Buddhism can give one a
kind of sense of one's own agency and
one's own consciousness as something
that is more fundamental than any
fleeting thought or feeling and as I say
if you don't believe in these negative
repetitive thoughts that are so
characteristic of anxiety and depression
and if you are able to face the the
feeling or the sensation that goes along
with them then part of what you're doing
is you're kind of empowering your own
consciousness to realize that you are
bigger than your problem and as soon as
you make that kind of move and so you
have that kind of sense of agency then
you're a long way towards solving the
problem so to come back to where I
started with that their claim that I'm
making in a way you could be put in this
way that if you understand that that
mental illness that mental distress as I
say provided it doesn't get too severe
provided it doesn't become something
like a psychosis if you understand that
those things are passing things which
which need not give you need not condemn
you to a sense of these being who you
are or what you are that your
consciousness is bigger than these
things that is itself a huge clue to how
you can get beyond them so is CBT just
Seneca in
you know in an acronym as that you think
cognitive therapies kind of just the
reworking of very old truisms yeah so I
think the cognitive behavioral therapy
can be a very useful set of tools for
dealing with anxiety and depression I
think that mindfulness based cognitive
therapy or cognitive behavioral therapy
is the the best way to go I think that
mindfulness based approaches in this
area clearly go back to stoicism and or
to Buddhism or to Allied wisdom
traditions and in this way I think that
these kinds of philosophical starting
points are hugely valuable in terms of
getting us to understand the kind of way
which we can take care of ourselves and
give ourselves a kind of agency in power
which can seem to be very remote from us
if we are pursued by anxious or
depressing thoughts so cognitive
behavioral therapy is often presented in
this very kind of scientific and sort of
modern way but I think it's really
helpful to recapture the ancient
philosophical roots of it for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute of Arts and ideas
at IAI TV
you